je vous présente le super joueur dont je
vous ai parlé céline
[Musique]
les crevettes les crevettes presque dans
les crevettes le meilleur c'est la tête
la tête et avec les paillettes c'est
mouillé à ccc la fenêtre la merde merci
damien apk telle est la peine
je préférais notre époque on dirait tous
bégaie c'est un peu le concept de
l'équipe
et moi je m'appelle
et on n'est pas là pour ce mois sacré on
va faire comment pour gagner des matches
tu l'as bien dit que tu l'emmènes games
c'est juste une équipe de water polo en
transit pour tokyo sans aucune intention
de nuire à votre pays ici l'homophobie
c'est un sport national on se met en
mode furtif d'accord quelle chance
d'être née lexsi pas de couilles
vous les avez arrêté parce qu'ils sont
gays j'ai encore fait n'importe quoi
j'étais bien je m'adonne attend attend
tellement tordu au mieux
pour cause et si peur de nous
qu'est ce qui est si anormal à ce que
deux personnes du même sexe elle
physiquement j'ai jamais demandé
différent j'en peux plus moi de cette
obsession crie sa différence alors que
tout ce qu'on veut c'est comme tout le
monde si on a pu avoir des enfants si on
a pu se marier c'est grâce à des gens
comme eux qui combattent depuis des
années l'homophobie à grands coups de
talons aiguilles et de gay pride on est
les cravates rouler vers demain on les a
sauvés et tu comptes faire quoi la
maison
[Musique]
mais on faire on va crever c'est bien
moi je vous le dit
[Musique]
c'est quoi ça c'est un gros beauf
obama mais pas james bond qui pourtant
est gay james bond il est pas guy excuse
moi mais bale c'est tout le monde le
sait un peu non de toute façon avec vous
tout le monde est gay bah oui